[Musique]
bienvenue frédéric potier ça va bien on
va parler de votre dernière parution qui
va la fois votre premier roman puisque
jusqu'à présent vous aviez fait des
essais et qui s'appelle la menace 732
c'est aux éditions de l'aube et c'est un
thriller de politique-fiction
invention vous vous êtes vous êtes aidé
à vous êtes préfet vous êtes
actuellement délégué général à l'éthique
et à la conformité à l'atp
vous avez
des montres de cabinet à matignon à
l'assemblée nationale donc vous
connaissez très bien le des liens
internes de la politique
et puis d'ailleurs dans le roman il ya
un jeune conseiller matignon peut-être
qu'il faudrait 127
on ne parlera tout allait did we jusqu'à
présent vous aimez fait surtout des
essais on avait parlé ici même de votre
très bonne et c'est sûr sur pierre
mendès france la fois démocratique
on viendra d'ailleurs peut-être sur
comment on passe du de laisser aux
romans et qu'elle est peut-être la
liberté ou le plaisir on a écrit un
roman mais on va peut-être commencer par
le dit la menace
732 alors il faut expliquer ce que c'est
732 parce que peut-être que tout le
monde ne connaît pas moi je me suis à
quelle école andré charles martel raid
732 les arabes à poitiers mais bien sûr
c'est une date en 732 cette fameuse
bataille de poitiers mais ce cas c'est
intéressant c'est quand on regarde la
réalité historique et pas forcément le
roman national on se rend compte que
cette fameuse bataille on n'est pas
certain qu'elle ait eus en 732 on n'est
pas certain qu'elle ait eu lieu à
poitiers se mettaient à toute date ou
peut-être
c'est peut-être dans ce coin là on ne
sait même pas trop sûr que deux qui
hélas n'est pas complètement sûr du
caractère confessionnel de la bataille
c'est qu'on a des doutes historique
assez nombreux assez fort alors même que
732 charles martel c'est un symbole
puissant chez certains groupuscules
d'extrême-droite s'est fixée il arrête
des arabes voici donc il rappelé le
premier qui lutte contre l'immigration
en gros c'est ça absolument c'est aussi
on prend un vocabulaire très actuelle on
pourrait dire que c'est le premier qui
dit le grand remplacement quand même
tellement aimé mais derrière tout ça ce
qui a certes annoncé qu'il ya des
identifications extrêmement puissante
efforts de groupuscules d'extrême droite
à cette date à ce personnage c'est un
martel et donc moi je me suis inspiré de
toute cette logorrhée d'extrême droite
pour construire un roman avec un
groupuscule qui n'existe pas mais qui
aurait pu aurait pu exister qui
s'appelle martel 732 dire très
intéressant le la question de la
référence ou même du référé historique
nous disait récemment par exemple on
disait par exemple des socialistes qui
avaient rejoint la nuit parce que
c'était bourgeois de calais c'est aussi
bon avec la corde au cou donc on voit
bien le symbole qu'est ce que ça nous
dit où folle et de le référer historique
ça me dit que l'histoire nous donne des
leçons je crois qu'on a un vieux pays
avec un goût assez prononcé pour
l'histoire et on parle des bourgeois de
calais mais on se traite souvent de 2min
quoi on se traite souvent de trade
défaitiste on parle souvent de la
débâcle on parle souvent de l'étrange
défaite de marc bloch et donc je crois
qu'il ya un goût français qui était très
nationale quand même qui est très
particulier qu'on retrouve pas forcément
dans tous les pays sur l'histoire sur
l'histoire politique et je crois que ça
irrigue très largement notre littérature
et notre note débat médiatique
d'ailleurs est peut-être un peu fausse
d'ailleurs il y aurait un sens de
l'histoire enfin cette voie là alors moi
je crois pas qu'ils aient le sens du
soulagement que ya les avancées et des
reculs on vient de le voir aux états
unis d'ailleurs tu as la redescendre la
cour suprême sur l'avortement et je
pense pas qu'ils aient des faits cliquer
je pense pas que nos démocraties
notamment où l'état de droit ce soit
quelque chose qui serait forcément
inéluctable il maintenant et sur lequel
on pourrait parvenir et c'est pour ça
que moi j'ai voulu écrire un roman un
polar thriller qui met en scène ou si ça
c'est à dire le malaise démocratique nos
fragilités et nos différentes tensions
alors le roman vrai c'est très étrange
quand on dit le début du roman parce
qu'on se dit assez d'hommes politiques 6
où ça commence par les élections
présidentielles et comme on sort de
l'élection présidentielle on en est là
alors oui on voit bien que c'est un
roman parce que c'est une femme qui est
élu de femmes d'où la gauche radicale on
peut dire ça comme ça très faiblement
élus ric-rac ric rac l'élection est
d'ailleurs contestée face à un candidat
face à l'extrême droite un caezar
absolument
le kobo comment vous montrer derrière
c'est ça un pays où vous en parler très
divisée très fragile
penser que c'est un peu la situation
qu'on vit est déjà aujourd'hui un pôle
en sait un peu les prémices de la
situation politique actuelle or c'est
vrai que ce roman moi je les écris il ya
maintenant à peu près un an je l'écris à
l'été 2000 21 je les corrige et au
moment où trump contester sa non
réélection aux états unis avec
l'envahissement du vue du capitole et
donc c'est vrai que cette situation de
tension de crise démocratique moi c'est
quelque chose qui m'obsède
arrondissement que les écrivains et qui
écrit pour exorciser leurs angoisses il
ya un petit peu de sa moye gier tiens si
notre démocratie française va s'y est
complètement et donc la façon de mettre
en garde ses aussi d'écrire des romans
des fictions et un président mal élu ou
une présidente très mal élues qui doit
faire face à une crise de légitimité bah
c'est pas une hypothèse complètement
farfelu vous avez raison de rappeler la
référence à trump parce que c'est ça
qu'on voit et qu'on voit de plus en plus
souvent même chez nous on voit que les
bras les résultats des élections sont de
plus en plus contesté
il a volé l'élection
évite le président est mal élu alors
même que la démocratie c'est un choix
collectif et donc c'est ce qui se
déplacent qui font ce choix là donc il
n'y a pas de il n'y a pas d' absurdité
démocratique ce qui est lui il est élu
il est là et il doit gouverner donc la
question qui se pose pour celui qui est
élu c'est est ce qu'il faut gouverner et
appliquer son programme à tout prix même
si le programme est intenable ou est-ce
qu'il faut déjà faire des compromis
trouvé des et qui dit le début du
compromis est ce que c'est pas le début
d'une compromission et donc c'est ça qui
est complètement dans l'actualité j'ai
fait exprès je joue alors dans cette
france donc très déchiré quoi enfin
qu'est vraiment diviser ou en effet la
con de on conteste l'élection même de la
présidence de la république il ya un
groupe de militaires
qui sera semblait alors évidemment cela
au corps ces défections mais ça nous
fait penser à ce qui s'était passé c'est
le 21 avril date symbolique avouer que
j'étais là le 21 avril c'est quand le
pen arrive au deuxième tour 21 avril
dernier avec une tribune d des
militaires justement qui est très proche
oomu de grands rappelé ban près que vous
utilisez dans le roman je crois qu'il
n'est pas dans leur tribune des qui est
très proche de la tribune que dont vous
parlez dans votre livre alors ça c'est
aussi une technique d'écriture moi je me
suis vraiment inspiré de beaucoup donc
les deux tribunes des généraux et des
militaires elle existe les groupuscules
avec des membres armés va des membres
des forces armées avec des gros casier
judiciaire là aussi j'ai rien inventé
j'ai changé les noms j'ai un peu changé
de lieu etc mais c'est des trucs qu'on
retrouve dans les journaux un an figaro
dans marianne et là encore moi j'ai pas
fait preuve d'une imagination débordante
c'est simplement j'ai essayé de relier
des faits divers des situations des
écrits des menaces des mises en garde
qui pourrait être vu comme complètement
éclaté alors même qu il me semble que
derrière il ya un contexte
une volonté de remettre en cause de cet
acquis démocratiques et donc la façon
aussi d'alerter les citoyens si c'est
d'écrire un roman parce qu'évidemment le
roman la fiction le polar le thriller
politique permet de dire beaucoup plus
de choses et de donner aussi une
dynamique à tout ça mais je reviens à
cette tribune qui est qui est très
proche encore une fois de celle qui est
publiée dans notre livre donc on crève
de faim parler du délitement générale de
la situation et ça se terminer par ce
qui était bon et c'est un peu la même
chose dans le livre on sait pas si c'est
une menace ou
si ça va passer à la réalité c'est à
dire que disant voilà il va falloir
qu'un jour quelqu'un puisse intervenir
pour remettre de l'ordre dans tout ça
quoi et il entendu l'armée est et ce qui
est passionnant c'est que en fait entre
la réalité et la fiction on peut jouer
on peut jouer avec le lecteur et dans
les grands écrivains qui ont fait des
hommes magnifique avec cette technique
là il ya james ellroy par exemple
qu'elle crie sur l'assassinât de john
fitzgerald kennedy ou en fait on lit un
roman ni un polar et on sait plus qui
leur est ce qu'il faut quoi tu es
tellement on est enserré tellement on
est immergé dans cette dans cette
réalité dans cette chose du passé deux
mois j'ai voulu un peux m'inspirer de ça
en prenant des choses très réelles des
gens qui existe des faits historiques
avec une trame et une intrigue qui elle
est pour le coup complètement inventé
dédié évidemment quand on écrit ce genre
de roman c'est aussi ses craintes qu'on
peut exprimer vous aviez été
impressionné par justement la tribune de
ces militaires oui moi j'avais été assez
assez bousculé quand même parce que on a
quand même en france une armée qui est
très républicaine qui est très légaliste
là mais il ya aussi dans l'histoire de
france une une
un vieux fond aussi de quoi ya
18 brumaire
le général de gaulle en 58 qui revient
et donc oui on va retrouvé sous la plume
de généraux ou deux généraux à la
retraite des menaces et des caddies
menace de sédition moi ça m'a un peu ça
m'a un peu revue et ouais ouais ça m'a
un peu bousculé je me suis intéressé
c'est bizarre mais ça doit dire quelque
chose quand même d'un climat général est
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
réutiliser ce vecteur de la tribune et
militaires d'autant que cette tribune à
un rivet encore une fois c'est un 21
avril mais peu importe il paraît qu'ils
ont pas fait exprès baup 20 pas
dans un climat quand même bien il ya des
sondages il y avait des sondages et ses
passings c'est toujours faim et qui sont
très récents et qui montrait qu'il vous
faut une majorité de français qui ne
serait pas opposé un régime autoritaire
quoi absolument il ya une vraie
tentation autoritaire il ya un vrai une
vraie fascination je crois pour le
césarisme dans le sang le mythe du
sauveur le l'homme la femme qui va nous
sauver toutes les situations et
d'ailleurs dans notre histoire politique
c'est ce sauveur il a pris différents
visages jeanne d'arc clemenceau de
gaulle napoléon on a quand même une
histoire de france qui est centrée sur
le lait les grandes figures et c'est eux
qui arrivent à nous sortir complètement
du du bus trains et donc c'est vrai que
cette cette volonté de dire finalement
notre système démocratique marche pas la
démocratie c'est compliqué les partis
politiques arrivent pas à 100 tant est
que ça et s'ils ont renversé la table et
si on passait à autre chose et c'est
vrai que les sondages montrent ça montre
que quand même il ya comme un vrai doute
ce qui a parfois aussi des sondages sur
si tu voudrais pas un gouvernement
technocratique disant finalement avoir
des élus qui connaissent rien est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas besoin de quelques
fois râler que le gouvernement le plus
des technocrates et qu'on ait eu ces
vigies exactement avec bousquet etc et
l'iddri donc ça a été un fier d'être un
spécialiste un ils étaient tous des
spéciales de l'art en matière c'étaient
les grands spécialistes et c'est
justement une négation même de la
démocratie qui consiste à dire qu'on a
tous collectivement le droit d'avoir une
question ou d'avoir un avis sur des
questions de santé de sécurité petit
étrangères même si comme vous et moi on
n'est ni médecin ni peu c'est vous et il
ya quelque chose que l'on ressent
évidemment dans votre religion votre
livre et qui est je crois très fort et
peut-être qu'on ne perçoit pas comment
on va le percevoir c'est qu'au fond la
démocratie est fragile elle est très
fragile et vous avez rappelé est alors
mon expérience à matignon à l'assemblée
nationale c'est ce qui m'a beaucoup
frappé mois au cours du dernier
quinquennat c'est la fragilité de ces
institutions qu'on voit très robuste
parce qu'on parle tout le temps de la
vème république
après sur ses affiliés du 49-3 de ce
cette rationalisation du débat au
parlement alors qu en fait derrière il
ya toujours des hommes et des femmes
avec leurs doutes avec leurs
questionnements avec leurs ambitions
avec leurs limites intellectuelles hors
limites physiques aussi l'épuisement ça
existe et donc moi je voulais aussi
rappelé à que le prêt ni ce n'était pas
forcément un super héros que le
président n'était pas doté de super
pouvoirs et donc ses fragilités là qui
sont inhérentes à l'activité humaine et
et et aux sciences sociales si on
élargit un petit peu on trouve qu'on a
un peu tendance à l'oublier on oublie
que derrière les institutions il ya des
hommes et que ces institutions peuvent
s'effondrer lorsque les hommes et les
femmes s'effondre et ce qui peut tout à
fait river un contexte de crise une
agression extérieure un attentat une
pression médiatique extrêmement forte
une absence de majorité qui fait que
prendre les décisions très dures dans
ces contextes là et a donné à tout le
monde seulement est ce que quand on
regarde justement l'état de la
démocratie
témoin cette fragilité dont on parle et
que vous souteniez dans ce livre et
quand on touche beaucoup en lisant ce
roman
ou folle et est ce que les démocrates
ont raté quelque chose non je crois pas
je crois que la démocratie a besoin de
démocrates d'abord et c'est inhérent à
la démocratie d'avoir un questionnement
sur ce qu'on fait avec quels moyens
comment et moi je mangeais un grand
défenseur de la démocratie un grand
admirateur de pierre mendès france mais
je vois bien la façon dont nos opposants
notamment des régimes autoritaires met
le doigt là dessus en disant mais en
fait votre votre truc ça marche pas quoi
regardez c'est efficace la démocratie ça
a abouti à l'élection de trump ou boris
johnson là où nous on a un quasi de sark
est très fort et puis un secrétaire
général du parti communiste chinois qui
lui rayonne dans le monde et donc je
vois bien cette stratégie là qui
consiste un peu à déconsidérer les
démocrates mais je pense que notre
système démocratique il est beaucoup
plus puissant parce que justement il
repose sur les citoyens eux mêmes et ça
il faut le rappeler est il faut le
rappeler alors même que certains n'y
croient pas du tout et veulent remettre
en cause tout ça et donc les
groupuscules d'extrême droite ait existé
gilson plus en plus violents d'ailleurs
je regardais en venant à bordeaux il ya
eu une descente dans un quartier assez
populaire donc cette violence de la
politique elle et elle est quand même
réelle elle est très présente
aujourd'hui en france justement revenons
au moment donc on a dit voilà cette
élection très contestée d'une présidente
plutôt très à gauche
cette menace des militaires nos coups
d'état et tout le tout le liban fin et
d'une grande partie 10 c'est de savoir
est-ce qu'ils vont passer à l'acte au
bras alors voit pas on va pas révélé ça
mais il ya des choses très intéressantes
viennent jeunes une jeune femme
policier qui enquête justement sur ces
milieux d'extrême droite et dont on va
peut-être y revenir c'est intéressant et
puis il ya il ya un court cousin vente à
sciences po mais ça vous tient à coeur
je pense c'est inconscient des coups
d'état justement c'est l'histoire des
coups d'état et et vous disent tu es
tout un tas de toute une série de coups
d'état comme vous dit à la france nous
avons avec eux napoléon iii elle est
peut-être deux bouts l'arrivée de de
gaulle 58 elle sait ce que c'est les
coups d'état c'est ce que c est moi ça
m'a beaucoup amusé de mettre des petites
tranches de cotation serait dans ce
polar la s'avère être un dessin ça
peut-être comprend faire un essai un
jour moi j'ai voulu simplement mettre un
petit peu de connaissances historiques
parce que ça m'amuse et de manière très
très très modeste un très haut mais au
pas tiqué dans dans ce roman mais
n'empêche que c'est intéressant de
rappeler que les coups d'état en france
on a une vraie tradition du coup d'état
un bonaparte louis napoléon le 2
décembre les années 30 avec les ligues
et charles de gaulle certains historiens
parlent de casques ou des 50 mais
seulement pour dire que quand même la
pression militaire là la pression aussi
de l'entourage avec jacques foccart
xterra fin
vous avez publié un livre sur 20 des
français d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
laquelle mendès france s'opposera
toujours au régime de la cinquième revue
locale et a toujours considéré que la
vème république était issu d'un coup de
force et qui pouvait pas lui demander de
france démocrates républicains affirmé
assumer cette création institutionnel
sur cette base là et donc c'est
intéressant de rappeler ça et c'est
intéressant aussi de mettre en lumière
l'histoire des autres coups d'état en
1917 la révolution d'octobre lénine
trotsky et puis plus près de nous et
nous chez nos chais en 73 l'espagne en
1900 on se souviens pas très bien de ce
mal c'est vrai que les types et apeurés
digues et que ça ça a tourné court grâce
à juan carlos d'ailleurs grâce au roi
d'espagne qui ravit avait pris en otage
on a complètement oublié ça mais
d'ecofin un colonel à débarque dans le
parlement espagnol avec une centaine de
deux gendarmes et militaires il prend en
otage le premier ministre l'opposition
les parlementaires pour mettre fin à l'
évolution démocratique de l'espagne est
celui qui sauva l'espagne de cette
tendance là c'est le jeune roi l'époque
royale dans ce groupe je pense qu'il est
important
et parce qu'il a été élevé par les
politiques quand on parle franco et il
le roi d'espagne refuse ça et c'est le
début de la démocratie espagnole mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on se dit
là ça a échoué mais si ça avait marché
marché je sortais du franquisme enfin
voilà donc et est finalement
mettre des chars dans la rue des soldats
dans la rue prendre d'assaut une place
c'est pas si compliqué que ça et on l'a
vu aux états unis alors c'est très
frappant 4 1 parce que là où on parle
beaucoup du niveau de ce qui s'est passé
au capitole à la fin l'extrême fin du
mandat de trappes et et maintenant on a
la conviction que c'était une sorte de
coup d'état alors d'avoir moi j'ai
complètement halluciné je passais
souvent oui devant mon écran voir des
images de type avec des déguisements
d'indiens torse nu rentrée au capitole
en plein milieu de washington alors
c'est quand même un des lieux les plus
sécurisés au monde enfin qu'ils étaient
censés les lieux les plus sécurisés du
monde et de voir cette foule là qui se
masse et un président américain trump
qui refusé de condamner de cannes tout
ça moi je regardais la télé américaine
je m'étais branché rock et la même
peut-être et qu'il allait n'attise bien
sûr je me suis branché sur cnn et
j'étais atterré et je me suis dit ah
ouais mais là ce que fait trump ça va
donner des idées je ne pense pas que le
truc soit complètement neutre et ne
donnera lieu à aucune suite et donc
c'est pour ça que cette question du coup
d'état du coup d'état démocratique ou du
coup de force elle n'est pas
complètement neutre dans ces moments là
ou pas l'abstention est extrêmement
élevé finalement il ya des tentations
autoritaires ça marche bien dans des
dictatures et donc
ça ça donne lieu à
une vision la démocratie qui est très
fragile et donc moi j'ai voulu faire
émerger et faire évoluer mes personnages
une capitaine de police et un général
une prof de sciences po dans ce milieu
là et les faire interagir et ce qu'est
ce que j'en viens au fond au
questionnement qu'on assure sur 7 sur
cette démocratie alors vous dites
enfin votre enquêteurs enquêtent sur
haut-fond les menaces qui viennent de
l'extrême droite est ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui ça vient plutôt de ce
côté là on a eu dans l'histoire de
france avec l'action directe un quelque
chose qui était qui venez plutôt de
l'extrême gauche s'il y avait une menace
aujourd'hui de la démocratie elle vient
plutôt de ce côté là oui vient plutôt de
ce côté là alors évidemment les années
2015 ont été traumatisés par les
attentats islamistes
et en fait ce que j'essaye de montrer
dans ce temps là et dans le dialogue
entre les salles se crée les militaires
et le pouvoir politique c'est finalement
qu' on peut pas voir une hiérarchie des
menaces il ya différentes menaces qui
viennent de milieux très différents et
il faut tout les couvrir et donc je fais
dire un moment à la chef des services
secrets que il ya cette menace du
terrorisme islamisme mais il y a
extrême droite qui peuvent arriver
d'ailleurs c'est arrivé aux etats unis
c'est arrivé à christchurch en nouvelle
zélande avec des fous furieux armés qui
étaient complètement convaincu de lutter
contre cette fameuse théorie du grand
remplacement mais on peut avoir
différentes menaces comme ça qu'ils se
manifestent avec des des réactions qui
sont absolument nécessaires et bon j'ai
pas dévoiler un peu plus longtemps mais
comme ça d'avoir des forces de sécurité
réactive sur toutes les formes de
menaces il ya et alors il ya quelque
chose qui est ainsi très très fort dans
ce dans ce roman on l'a dit il ya ces
militaires qui est là qui vont peut-être
passer à l'acte et et tenté un coup
d'état et il ya aussi des militaires qui
sont très républicain qui sont pour la
légitimité de la république qui la
défendent même si et là on à pouvoir
très à gauche même si on se dit que
probablement ils n'ont pas les mêmes
idées que le le pouvoir en place alors
c'est moi je place la nage entre garage
invente un personnage chef d'état-major
des armées que je place dans une
situation impossible parce que la
nouvelle président de la république qui
lui arrive avec un programme aurait dit
on va arrêter l'armé nucléaire mais on
va partager notre siège au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu avec les allemands eon
va réduire le budget des armées de 10%
donc je place ce général l'association
absolument impossible et donc je
m'interroge sur
sur la façon dont il va pouvoir gérer
ces contraintes la et où va se porter sa
fidélité est-ce que sa fidélité va se
porter à l'autorité démocratique qui le
donneur d'ordres légitime ou est ce que
il va porter sa loyauté vers ses
compagnons d'armes parce qu'il sent bien
il renoncer à l'armé atomique dans un
monde extrêmement dangereux où la
situation est très fragile et instable
partout dans le monde c'est très
dangereux pour la france et donc ça
rejoint à cette question des engagements
de campagne et donc voilà moi j'essaye
de aussi ne pas faire des personnages
qui seraient tous complètement
caricaturaux et donc j'essaye de faire
en sorte que cette armée française
j'essaie de la montre est un peu dans sa
diversité avec des vrais pu républicain
d'autres plutôt tenté par ses aventures
autoritaire et donc à ses relations
entre ces deux camps ont aussi beau spa
dans les dents les dirigeants de l'armée
ou la police
on est plutôt tentés par l'extrême
droite ou pas c'est trop ça se dit
souvent mais ça se dit souvent il n'y a
pas de soldats mais votre sort avec
essaie d'aller sonder les coeurs de tous
les skieurs mais vous avez l'allèle plus
de la majorité des cadres de la ville
qui sont proches de rassemblement
national moi je crois pas qu'ils aient
de majorité de ce type là j'aimerais
tant énervé très républicaine à
remettrai plus ken police qui est
républicaine gendarmerie
donc je crois pas que on se place dans
une situation du type sud américaine on
aurait un colonel comme sa fantasque
général tapioca qui dès qu'ils arrivent
et qui prend le pouvoir comme dans comme
dans tintin je pense pas que ce soit le
cas mais n'empêche qui a des petits
groupes qui sont très travaillés par
tout ça y compris dans des grandes
écoles très prestigieuse
militaires et on a aussi des fichiers s
les services secrets ont répertorié des
militaires fichier est ce qu'ils font
l'objet d'une surveillance à raison de
leurs risques pour les autorités de la
république d'ailleurs vous
entrez dans le détail du roman mais il y
a en effet un certain nombre de
militaires qui voilà qui sont engagés
dans cette action et on voit très bien
que les services secrets savent très
bien qu'ils sont ce qu'ils ont fait
parfois ils ont été renvoyés d'ailleurs
de l'armée ont les fils joris il ya mon
attention la direction ministère de la
défense qui est chargé de faire ça
justement dessin surveiller ses propres
troupes et des gardes d'écarter les
brebis galeuses mais c'est un travail
qui n'est pas forcément évident et et
c'est un travail qui doit être assez
assez difficile son plan la loyauté aux
siens d'aller vite à les surveiller ses
petits camarades alors de deux ans pour
terminer va voi à 0 jeudi c'est notre
premier roman vous êtes passé à la
fiction
qu'est ce que ça vous a apporté d'abord
de la liberté suppose de front c'est pas
tout à fait vous va peut-être alors que
dans 1 1 s'est il faut être plus plus
précis
d'abord c'est une grande joie une grande
jubilation d'écrire en toute liberté
parce qu'un essai notamment un essai
politique comme celui que j'avais fait
sur pierre mendès france il faut
vérifier les dates il faut vérifier les
citations il faut vérifier les chiffres
vont pas faire de d'erreurs ou de
lecture anachronique d'une situation là
où le romancier peut vraiment se lâcher
quoi donc moi je me suis vraiment lâchés
en utilisant des choses qui sont réelles
en utilisant des lieux que moi j'avais
plus grenelle 1 matignon et place
beauvau l'assemblée nationale des
situations aussi quand moi je décris
l'écriture d'un discours en toute
urgence ou un communiqué de presse ou de
crise ah ça je les fais avec as neuf
défaites valls etc un cortège officiel
qui passe toute allure donc pour moi ça
c'est pas de la fiction n'est par contre
le fait de pouvoir relier tout ça et
puis de pouvoir réécrire une intrigue
romanesque un vrai polar un roman noir
ça c'était vraiment enfin moi j'ai
vraiment pris mon pied l'été c'est quoi
c'est qu'il faut faire passer des faits
avant les idées dans un roman c'est
l'action qui devrait
après quoi enfin on a déduit quoi
presque de l'action absolument et puis
bon moi j'ai écrit un thriller politique
fair que j'essaie de faire en sorte que
le lecteur tiennent le roman et ne
puisse pas leur poser
d'abord ces déchets vite très court il
faut dire donc on a et c'est vrai qu'on
a envie d'aller plus loin à chaque fois
qu'on colis et en même temps
il ya autre chose là dedans et c'est
vrai que nous avons le litre est très
simplement je leur montre donc
hier il ya aussi qu' on a un petit peu
froid dans le dos quand on lit ça parce
qu'on se dit ça pourrait se produire à
bas je ne dis pas que c'est possible
jeudi par contre que ce n'est pas
complètement impossible le scénario
arrive n'est pas possible merci merci à
merveille avec le style donc je
l'appelle de titres des livres la menace
732 et c'est aux éditions de l'aube
merci à bientôt
[Musique]